Now the last thing we'd like to cover before we close out today is creating emissive materials.
And essentially emissive material can help with the global illumination of the scene
as well.
So we still start with a basic material and we just change the shading model to unlit.
The unlit shader model uses fewer instructions than a default lit model and is often enough
to define an emissive material.
So we just want to multiply a color node and a constants mode which essentially gives us
the intensity.
Convert them both to parameters, create a material instance and then we'll test out
the material.
So that's the last kind of workshop for the day.
Let's jump into the editor again and let's set this up before we close out.
So back in our materials folder, I'm going to right click, I'm going to go to material,
I'm going to call this M underscore emissive and hit enter.
Enter again to open it up.
Now the thing that we do here differently than what you've done previously is without
anything selected, you want to go to the shading model on the left hand side, go to default
unlit.
That will take off certain values here.
So we want three nodes here.
We want a vector three which hold down three on your keyboard.
We want a constants one just to multiply this.
So hold down one and then we also want a multiply.
So hold down M on your keyboard for multiply.
So three and left click, one on left click, M for multiply and left click.
Let's drag these into here.
Let's create this basic setup straight into the emissive color.
Now I'm going to convert this to a parameter and call this emissive color.
I'm going to right click, convert to a parameter and call this intensity.
I'll set the intensity to one by default and then I'll just create some kind of color
just as our nice emissive color.
Hit okay.
Now let's just save this.
Now we'll create an instance of this just because good workflow will keep maintaining
what we've previously spoken about.
So even though it's a quick example, we'll create a material instance.
I'm just going to call this mi underscore emissive.
Let's just call this, I might even just call this pink instead.
You might call it 01, you might call it pink, whatever you'd like to call it.
And we just want to make sure these are all ticked.
Let's see what's happening here.
So let's go inside.
Let's go to our shapes panel.
Let's drag in a sphere here.
Let's scale it into position.
Let's drag and drop this emissive.
And you'll see we're getting some illumination bounce.
And that's a really nice feature of Unreal Engine 5 with the lighting system.
So we're getting some bounce off the emissive here.
So we might want to change this intensity to maybe make it a ball of light,
like a sunlight or something like this.
And you'll see that we instantly start getting this flood and this fill of color in the scene.
So I'm just going to create a bit more real estate here just so you can see what's happening.
So again, because it's a material instance, we can change this at runtime.
So if you wanted to change this in your scene at runtime, you could do so.
Green is not the nicest color, but we'll go with it for now.
But you can see scaling the intensity, really nice power over the scene or control over the scene,
depending on what you like.
And just using on the emissive materials,
really nice way to just add a bit of flavor to your scene.
So hopefully that's a useful little tip for creating unlit emissive materials.